même si la plage de verdun est
officiellement fermée ça n'arrête pas
ceux qui veulent se rafraîchir là c'est
la canicule est fait encore plus chaud
est à la maison il fait 30 degrés donc
vous voyez là on prend l'air on va dans
l'eau fraîche et on se rafraîchit
mais certains repartent aussitôt arrivé
parce que la pandémie n'est pas encore
derrière nous je m'en veux juste
rappeler les pieds de bébé pour
l'essayer puis j'ai vu la foule de monde
je vais partir je trouve que beaucoup
trop mon la ville de montréal a
enclenché son plan chaleur extrême
une carte interactive montre quels lieux
publics climatisés ou encore jeux d'eau
sont ouverts cette canicule ci est
vraiment particulière c'est vraiment de
réinventer et revoir les procédures avec
les consignes tout en respectant les
consignes de la santé publique par
exemple les piscines qui vont ouvrir
progressivement à partir de samedi vont
accueillir un nombre de visiteurs
restreint limiter le temps de baignade
et maintenir les vestiaires fermi à
laval il faudra s'inscrire en ligne à
l'avant si on prévoit aller à la piscine
et si on préfère par précaution rester à
la maison et éviter les endroits publics
il y à d'autres solutions on n'a pas
tous nécessairement la climatisation à
la maison puis les endroits où on va
chercher un répit à leurs climatiques
sont pas tous ou voir donc comment on
peut réfléchir chez soi peut se
rafraîchir à l'intérieur aussi en
prenant un bain froid une douche froide
il y a ceux qui sont forcés de
travailler à la chaleur comme sur les
chantiers de construction
aiguillon de la et ongles aux emprunts
directs ou souvent le joug des plus
tolérer un gars qui fait chaud
aujourd'hui c'est exceptionnel de ce
fait longtemps qu'on n'est pas sûr mais
on est des travailleurs ça va bien bien
on fait attention on est bien protégé et
lorsque le port du masque devient trop
difficile avec cette chaleur la santé
publique recommande de le laisser de
côté
mais de respecter une distance de 2
mètres entre les personnes ici fanny but
c'est un mec nicole radio canada
montréal